think that when a politician does that
when they take the time and effort to
get to know the community when they
visit the mosque when they go there was
actually a report recently of a man who
who claimed he said I hated Muslims John
Dutcher will straight-out tell you what
he thought of Muslims I actually hated
and he said that once he got neighbors
who were Muslims and he interacted with
them he was in tears and he said myself
he thought I'd win with her headdress on
you know I just would sneer at him
dutcher was surrounded by the people he
loathed but Muslims moving in moved him
it took this to come yeah to to wake me
you know wake me up yeah a change of
heart for the man who didn't realize he
had such a big heart his whole attitude
change and now he's like their big
brother so for politicians for anyone
out there if you take the effort and you
you go and you meet your neighbors you
go to the local mosque and you'll see
that it there's so much more we have in
common so many so many unifying forces
that we have is a lot of commonality
right I mean if people would focus on
that and make that it's so powerful that
human connection in this LOM by itself
is so powerful there's so much good
there and I think a lot of these people
you know would take the time to come
visit us visit the mosque get to know
your Muslim neighbor ask those tough
questions we address them here at the
same show right and as a clinical
psychologist hate that doesn't that just
breed more hate it sure does it sure
does I think if we are instilling the
sphere and people it's fear what it does
it is mobilizes people and it really
makes them act irrationally so the more
fear that is instill in the hearts of
the people the more radically they react
to that so you find that there's a lot
of hate crimes you find that people are
they are overreacting and so definitely
if we can instill that sense of
commonality focus on that then it truly
makes a difference and what's been very
beneficial I think the you know we
always say that everything that happened
there's a wisdom behind and they've all
had and what has happened is that it has
galvanized so many people so many
good-hearted non-muslims to to solidify
and to join an in solidarity with the
Muslims so I find that a lot of hair is
coming out of all this
a lot of good is coming out that's what
I'm saying look for the good there are a
lot of the people are coming out of the
Woodworks right writing a lot of
injustice is a lot of this hate pointed
towards the Muslims yes I like this is
on justice not right and they're getting
to know the Muslims there is that
because you saw the prayer that Muslims
are pretty yeah they're without a few
default is beautiful and when you tune
into the Deen showing you really get to
know what Islam is about you have a
different understanding a totally
different perspective we're going to be
right back we got to talk we haven't
even touched upon the five pillars of
marriage yes we're going to talk about
it more you want to save your marriage
we're going to get into what these are
the top ten characteristics for conflict
was looking into a taste of all the work
that's on your site without here on a
detail don't go anywhere
[Applause]